now what do you want me to say
oh
daniel
you've come here and you've brought good
and wealth but you have also brought
your bad habits as a backslider you've
lusted after women and you have
abandoned your child your child that you
raise you have abandoned all because he
was sick and you have sinned so say it
now i am a sinner
say it louder i am a sinner i'm a sinner
louder daniel i am a sinner i am a
sinner i am sorry lord i am sorry lord i
want the blood the blood you have
abandoned your child
i've abandoned my childhood i will never
backslide i will never backslide i was
lost but now i am found lost but now i'm
fine i have abandoned my child
say it say it
abandon my job say it louder say it
louder i've abandoned my child
i've abandoned my child
i've abandoned my boy
begged for the blood
just give me the bloody light let me get
out of here give me the blood lord
and let me get away do you accept jesus
christ as your lord and savior yes i do
get out of your devil
round
of the third revelation is your
spiritual god
you accept jesus christ as he our savior
yes i
[Music]
you be do from the burdens
[Music]